[Music]
my name is SE Kar I'm a a professor in
computer science in applied math at
Stanford and uh before that I was the
engineering lead for personalization at
Google and before that I had a small
company called CTIC which was a
personalized search engine uh which got
acquired by Google in
2003 uh my name is Seth I I was GSB 06
but left in ' 05 um and left because I
co-founded meibo along with two other
co-founders uh and meibo started as just
a web imim client was just like hey let
people get on uh to AOL or MSN at the
time via the web uh we quickly heard
from people that they wanted meibo in
their sites fundamentally to be a social
platform in their sites so today Mio's
distributed through thousands of sites
it's on like you know philly.com or
entertainmentweekly or TMZ as the social
platform in that site so it lets users
connect up with their friends on
Facebook or Twitter Myspace or uh
whatever kind of friends they want to
connect with uh when they go around the
web cool uh my name is Anna kapor I uh I
run a company called gravity and uh we
focus on personalizing the internet uh
before gravity I was at Myspace I was
the clo there uh where I I worked there
for a long time since it was a startup
helped build a lot of you know
socialization and social media on the
web and uh before that I studied
mechanical engineering here uh so that's
my background I don't have a business
background or anything but uh I really
enjoyed my time here it's nice to be on
the other side of the uh
classroom perfect so my name is Bo Pan
um um I did on theard Berkeley um in El
in computer science in 2006 I joined the
do at Stanford um B and basically I was
going to do my PhD here um uh wasn't
exactly um realized halfway through was
exactly M left in 2008 started clever
sense um which is uh it's it's a
personalization and the Machine learning
platform as it relates to location based
Services we focus on the locals um for
mobile and um yeah Bo stra it from 2008
to 2010 got it fund 2010 and we're
powering through it right now hi and I'm
the uh moderator my name is Howard Haron
bomb I work at a firm called August
Capital which is kind of a low key firm
you may not have heard of uh but you
probably heard of many of the companies
that the partners there have backed um
including seate sanch compact into it
Microsoft atheros uh zyink cybase and a
bunch of others um my lucky uh entrance
into the Venture business was I put the
first money into Skype and was on their
board and which was a really a wild ride
um so if you guys have interest in
companies in the future I'm the guy you
come and talk to
um so uh so let's talk about the topic
and I have a few questions and I thought
some of them I'll just go down and some
of them will just be directed at one
particular person so um on the first
question I'll start with bubach and
maybe we'll go down uh the line which is
you know the companies here um are based
on the premise that that your users are
willing to input their personal data uh
as part of using the service um and can
you explain what types of data that
people are willing to share using your
services and what's the value that you
provide in return for them doing that
absolutely so and if you can't hear back
there raise your hand and we'll I'll
shove the microphone down this
thrat um so uh so part of the good news
is that is that we living in a wide
generation I mean people are living
practically on Facebook and Twitter
right now so um as far as U essentially
what kind of data we be asking for um
the way our service works we are
analyzing the the the conversations that
we're seeing on the web as people are
writing reviews and whatnot on on
different particular outs U Outlets so
we're we have a new way of indexing user
generate content so people can actually
use our service without any sharing
anything with us um once we full out
launch it um so but then they can
further share with us um U VI are you
know Facebook connect um totally opt-in
service Facebook connect or eventually
for SC even Twitter so it's totally an
opin service so people can share however
much that they uh want to share and um I
mean privacy is a big deal thing um
basically I mean we're not going to
build a service if we're not going to
use our El so and we believe in um an
absolute matter of giving control to
users so if the there's going to be a
button on our service that it can delete
everything they've got with us and they
can see it so that's how we that's how
we see
it cool well uh just as as some kind of
basic background on on I think just data
in general so you know uh I think all of
us sort of experienced this uh this
notion of information overload uh where
you know over time the Technologies for
the creation of content are often
competing with the Technologies for the
distribution the the discovery of
content and so uh what we end up finding
is that major technology companies uh
will come in and create things that will
filter that content filter that data for
us so that we find more relevance within
it and early on you had companies create
directories then you had companies
create search uh ultimately even those
types of types of filters ended up
failing with the uh user generated
content and social data that was
entering the stream and uh companies
that were creating social filters like
Twitter Facebook Myspace and others
allows you to actually find great
content find great information by by uh
using your friends as a social filter uh
once again what we believe is that we're
on we're experiencing another phase of
information overload where the amount of
of user generated content of social data
that is you know available to all of us
that's accessible is overwhelming our
streams and so what we do at gravity is
that we listen to users we observe them
uh we take a look at what you're saying
on Twitter who you're following with
their saying uh what you're liking on
Facebook what you're sharing and we
build a holistic understanding of who
you are what you're interested in um so
if you are uh liking a story about the
iPad 2 on TechCrunch or if you check in
at a local sushi restaurant or if you
tweet about how great the surf is in
Santa Cruz we can build a really great
profile to understand who you are uh
from that what we end up doing is we
partner with third parties as a platform
so that they can tap into that data and
then personalize their experiences or
adapt them to users that access their
site so in the future um I kind of
imagine this world where you don't go to
you know accessing internet sites or
applications where they're all one siiz
fits all like going to see the New York
Times or going to CPN but it actually
adapts to you and your interest so the
best content for you starts to get
surface to the top and some of the noise
gets suppressed so that's what we're
doing at gravity um so the whole notion
of like what data you users give and
then what they get back for that's
interesting because it's really hot
right now right everybody's talking
about oh you know are people people
stealing people's data and are they
treating people's data kind of
appropriately um and so there's a lot of
work kind of amongst standard standards
bodies right now to say hey how should
our industry the internet industry which
is dependent on data right like
everything we do at some level depends
on users giving us data and then us
making something interesting out of it
and spitting it back how should we treat
it like what are the opt outs for users
and how much should users know about uh
kind of what happens to their data how
we're processing it and how easily like
I said should they be able to delete it
um so uh what I think is kind of
interesting is most users right they
probably don't care what happens with
their data as long as they understand
what the expectation of that application
is right so what I mean by that is look
at like the difference in the evolution
to use two companies that are not in
this panel between Facebook and Twitter
right like Twitter started as a very
very public data system like a user
gives it data user expects that it's
going to be public and Facebook started
as a private data system user gives it
data and they expect that it's going to
be private and Facebook has had a lot of
difficulty trying to move over to making
that expectation of privacy all of a
sudden become public right whereas
Twitter has had this really easy road
because they just created this default
expectation with users up front it's
like hey your your data is public and
that's what the user thought they were
getting so I think that at the end of
the day with users it's just about
expect like setting expectations it's
like do you said expectation that the
data is public or that it's private and
I think it's very hard to switch from
private to public it's much easier to go
public to private yeah I'll follow up on
what Seth was saying in that um I think
one really interesting thing about this
question is that the cultural norms
around uh the value that people perceive
and the risk that people perceive of
giving up their data is changing
dramatically uh I mean if you take a
look at the mid to late '90s there were
a lot of people who said said uh you
know I don't feel comfortable giving my
credit card to a website um and now
that's that's changed and you see that
not only with information that people
are willing to share with the service
but PE information that people are
willing to share with the public and
what happens is that um and this is a
really great opportunity I think for
startups because uh when companies do
come out they have an existing Community
with existing cultural norms and it's
hard to change that even though the over
it's hard to change that within the
community even though the overarching
cultural norms are changing and so for
example at Google when we switched from
uh being able to have user accounts and
Associate your user history with those
accounts um there was it was very
difficult to do um and we had to do a
lot we had to do a lot of communications
and a lot of putting controls into place
uh I think new search engines that
launch today will launch with the idea
of having your search history associated
with your account from the GetGo and
then you can be opted out um and so I
think that there's a really nice
opportunity for startups as these
cultural norms continue to evolve at
this rapid
Pace um so you know personalization
means different things to different
people and I think one of the challenges
of doing you know having this discussion
is when when Amit says personalization
versus when bobc says personalization it
might mean different things to them and
it might mean different things to you
guys as well so keep that in mind if you
have questions in the you know at the at
the end when we when we have a question
period so uh I'll start the next
question with Amit and if one of the
other guys want to jump in afterwards
feel free which is you know there was a
lot of talk about social graph and now
there's more and more talk about being
an interest graph out there um and so uh
how is uh the interest graph used for
for per for the internet and
personalization on the internet sure um
so so my background before was at at
Myspace and growing that company and and
starting to see where there was ANC
incredible amount of data about users
mainly uh who they were connected with
and so that was really the premise
behind a social graph is being able to
understand who the user is and who
they're attached to uh and then
understand that weighted Detachment
because we may have hundreds of friends
but there's only a few that were were
very closely associated with uh what the
interest graph does is it gets a notion
of of what we're attached to so what
sports do we like what industries are we
interested in uh What uh what you know
locations are we interested in as well
and understands the way attachment that
you have to those things those those
topics of interest and uh with the
social graph we've we've seen these
unbelievably amazing experiences and
value that's been unlocked with it um on
sites like Facebook as well as all the
applications that access it with the in
graph we'll see similarly these
unbelievably uh valuable applications of
it where as we use uh a mobile app or as
we access an internet website by
understanding who the user is uh what
their interests are we can actually
start to dynamically adapt that site to
to that user and as a result you have a
really engaging amazing experience where
you see a lot less of the noise that you
typically see on web pages and a lot
more of things that will actually
interest you so uh that's how we see an
interest graph and one of the things
that I think is just a a Nuance with
what we do is uh is we actually attach
people within that graph so uh if you
look at semantic technology the way that
that works is there's an ontology which
is a dictionary of terms that relate to
each other so um where Kobe Bryant is a
player for the Lakers which is an NBA
team he's also a celebrity in Los
Angeles and so those all exist as knows
within an ontology what we do is we
actually layer in a people graph on top
of those those interests and those
topics so we understand what people are
interested in then we can help you
actually Traverse through that graph
based on common interests with uh with
friends so uh all of us may be
interested in Stanford football and
because I'm also interested in the iPad
too if you look at at your relationship
with me and our common interest in
Sanford football you can actually direct
somebody to the iPad too uh via uh those
kinds of inferences so there's a lot of
complexity that goes into it but uh it
just goes to show that there's a lot of
power within it too where as we start to
apply that we'll start to actually be
able to filter all this information uh
that we're once again experiencing this
overload with on the internet
today um so I think interest like in in
the internet industry there the there's
the buzzword of the moment
and interest graph is definitely the
buzzword of the moment and I also think
that when any given person in the
internet industry says interest graph
they probably have no clue what they're
talking about and it's probably
different from the next person next to
them so with the exception of of course
actually how inv two years ago we
proposed the interest so that's but I
guess I'll say it as they just think
like you have your version of Interest
craft and you know what you're talking
about but everybody else's definition of
incraft I think is probably very
different from yours that's say uh and
so when you think about I guess the way
I approach it is you think about
people's relationship with other people
so it's like you've got your very very
close circle of friends right and you
probably like you SMS with them you I am
with them you call them okay then you
have your kind of second order friends
it's like the people who you wish you
could keep in touch with but you don't
have time to keep in touch with now um a
lot of the social stuff in the web today
has done a really really good job of
keeping you in touch with kind of your
close friends and you're now like with
the Advent of you know Facebook and to
some extent Twitter just social networks
in general second order friends really
good job you know Myspace is the same
thing right um but then there are all
these other people who you probably
share common interest with that you
could learn from and you just don't have
a good way to learn from those people
today right and if you think about all
the social stuff that's really kind of
default happened in the web today it's
about your friends but the thing is I'm
interested like I'm a pilot so I'm
interested in airplanes and I've
recently gotten into bicycling so I'm
interested in like you know bicycles uh
thing is only one of my other friends is
a pilot and only one of my other friends
really like religiously rides bicycles
so I can't use my social graph to learn
about cool stuff around airplanes or
bicycles so what I what I need to do is
somehow find these other people who I
overlap with from an interest
perspective and learn from them about
bicycles and airplanes right and so I
think like in my world of Interest graph
it's how can you use the fact that like
maybe you and I are both interested in
flying airplanes and then help connect
us out there on the internet and then I
can discover cool content or cool new
experiences because of that so like um
Bill Gurley and Max Levin were recently
on a panel at the Goldman Sachs
technology conference and they made a
very similar point they were kind of
like look there's Google all the way
over here on like I know I'm looking for
it it's algorithmic and it's like I want
to find out about airplanes and an
algorithm helps me find it and then
there's kind of Facebook over here and
it's like these are my friends and maybe
I have some interest overlaps with my
friends like we like the same kind of
music but we really don't care you know
my friends just don't care about the
same thing like bicing as I do there's
some Middle Ground which is based on
people and based on learning about our
interests based on people um and that
has not been done well yet and like I
know you're working on it in in ways and
we're working on way a lot of people are
trying to figure out how to do that
middle ground that yeah oh you can
go so I think in general I mean as I
mean going to follow up on what Seth was
talking about um the definition of
intercraft I think changes from U not
even just one company to another company
from one person to another person and
the intricacy comes from the fact that
how interest graph is defined both from
the domains that it covers let it be
from people's interest versus um um
items as we call it like items can be a
place it can be a brand it can be um a
company and how these relationships are
set up um it it it will have deep impact
on what the interest graph is going to
be used for um because just because
somebody mentions on their Facebook page
that I'm interested in movies doesn't I
mean doesn't mean a whole lot
and just because they they say I'm
interested in Rock Band doesn't again
the definition of that changes and how
in in each graph you you you you talk
about I mean literally the the
reliability of that information the
sentiment of that information you could
just say that you know and also inverse
of that you can say I I don't like rock
music I mean how those things are set up
in intr graph would actually have
implications on how the intr graph can
be used um talking about the notional
personalization and interest graph can
can be used for multiple things I mean
you can just find information that
matters to you based on how um uh the
graph is set up for a particular um
entity for a particular um let's say
brand like CNN or or a place versus how
your friends perceive it um these are
completely different things and and I
don't know if there's going to be one
single company who's going to have the
overarching encompassing one interc that
does it all for everybody I think um
it's much much more um interesting and
useful if you have a focused set of
graphs that are that are built to do
certain things and they have a very rich
and deep understanding of how these
relationships are set up so they can
come back and and use it for for a
specific purpose um because it's just
you know how um page rck was set up
originally in the old days I mean it was
accounting mechanism to find out what
the reliability of a particular keyboard
keyboard was um as it relates to other
websites and uh same thing with the
notion of Interest craft it's just to me
it's a lot it's just a lot more complex
because these relationships um change
change and these relationships are um
you know evolving as also people evolved
in it so um yeah I mean there just
different definitions of it and there
are different use case of it based on
how you set up your the graph
itself uh let me uh agree with Seth on
the buzzword aspect and also use that
basic uh use the basic principle
underlying the shift between the social
graph to the interest graph to help you
come up with new bu words
so so the idea is that we have basically
a set of nodes and a set of edges within
the nodes and the transition from the
social graph to the interest graph is
essentially you're labeling some of
these nodes with their interests well
you can label them with other things for
example reputations and so then you have
a reputation graph or uh expertise and
then you have an expertise graph uh and
then you can also do things like label
the edges themselves in terms of the
types of relationships or the type of
information that flows along those
relationships and so there's both
benefit around generating new buzzwords
but also to think about new kinds of
information interactions that happen on
graphs just using that principle of
continuing to further label these nodes
and these
edges um but a full disclosure sep is
one of our advisers so we learn a lot
from him so yeah so he has to kiss ass a
little bit
absolutely of
course I do it myself sometimes
um I I don't think you've ever kissed my
ass but we haven't met
before I actually to be full disclosure
uh August capital is an investor in
gravity a meets company and I tried to
be an investor in Seth company and had I
known you other guys I probably would
have tried to invest in YouTube there
you go um so what would um the ultimate
personalized experience look like um
what opportunities will emerge when like
everything in your life is captured
within the digital realm so why don't we
start with Seth on this one
who well I'll answer that question if
you can first tell me what the Ultimate
unpersonalized Experience will look
like um somebody who doesn't use the
internet um so I think it's I mean I
think that's a very hard question to
answer um I this is a little bit of
Brave New World like what could it be 10
5 10 years from now
where and maybe you can add into the
answer like is it too much at that point
does it is it actually a bad thing so I
mean I'll give I I'll give a couple of
uh I'll give a couple non- answers that
that answer somewhat related questions
um I think first
is I think right now algorithms for
personalization are not very good um I
think you have essentially two classes
of algorithms one is item based
collaborative filtering which is used on
things like Amazon uh and the second you
have modelbased type recommendations
which are used on um on uh for a lot of
other sites presumably with you guys and
and with you guys and um and there's a
lot and these algorithms have been
around for a very long time um and
there's a lot of opportunity for new
Innovations from the algorithmic side um
and I think when you get the those those
kinds of Innovations you'll have much
more highly specific type of
recommendations um so that's one is I
think there's room for Innovation on the
on on the algorithm side so that you
have a much higher specificity and it's
the kind of thing that you'll know when
you see it like Google search results
were so much better than alav Vista
search results um so I think that's one
kind of Brave New World of
personalization I think a second is as
you uh as more more kinds of data be
move to the web you have a lot of um a
lot of kinds of data that are not amable
to traditional keyword search and are
much more amable to personalized
recommendations I mean music being an
example but job search being an example
I mean there's some stat like 80% of
people are passively looking for a job
um real estate so on and so when you
combine these two and not to mention
things like video for example where for
entertainment needs it does really make
sense to do a keyword-based search so
when you have this combination of better
algorithms for personalization and new
types of data that are much more amable
for personalization that's I think the
two Trends that'll point towards the
ultimate personalization experience uh
if I knew the specific answer to that I
would probably just start a company
around that
so um I think as it's pretty difficult I
mean these things we we know things are
going to get more personalized because
there's the the problem of information
overload as amid was talking about is is
pretty obvious I mean it's just it we
living through that right now as more
and more um people are sharing and
there's more and more you're getting
bombarded by by information I mean it's
I mean you just right now we're all I
think living in a society it's just ad
driven I mean attention def defens
disorder is a real thing I mean everyone
is just all constantly getting B by
Twitter know Facebook I mean news sites
I me there's just so much happening I
think the the way you know we see it at
least I don't know it's going to be 20
30 or even like 5 years from now uh but
one thing that we'd like to Le work
toward is that um this notion of uh the
information finding you in the right
place the right time um obviously real
time um such that you know we we would
understand your relationship with with
you you know with things that you care
about and as they're moving around as
they're changing as something if if if
an if an event triggers that would
really really interest you U we would
find you and deliver it to you whether
you are on the web whether you're on the
go um much like I mean the vision would
be something I mean somebody who who
take care of you when you're on the web
you wouldn't get you don't need to see
through you know piles and P of
documents I mean right now I mean most
you know attorneys or Executives and
whatever they have assistants who
actually sift through stuff and say
these are the things you should pay
attention to these are your meetings
right here make sure you read this
document I mean that's what they do but
they human beings who are sifting
through that information and they also
understand your priorities so I think a
personalized world I mean our tagine is
personalizing the world around you is is
such that you would find the information
that a matter to you when you're on the
go and we would actually try to do an
experience of um we're very big on
Serendipity I mean search search so we
would actually do think on your behalf
when you're not thinking um and try to
deliver information as it as it would
relate to you um um
serously what so yeah I like to think
but I mean we're we you know to sort of
take it a little bit away from the being
too conceptual I think that there are
some things that we're seeing today that
where personalization is actually very
effective in the uh you know today and
in the near future and then to sort of
look where we go ahead in a few years um
we'll talk about that in a second too
but even today I think you know if you
look at practical applications of
personalization uh music is one where it
is very effective so my background at
Myspace I ran Myspace music and I was
there as one of my respons
responsibilities and we were part of
this revolution where music became very
social and I think that before that you
saw this I think I mean even to take a
step back from that for a second though
one of the things that personalization
does very effectively is it helps us
sift through a list of options and so
early on even before social DJs and
editors would help us sift through a
list of options so if it's a radio DJ or
an MTV DJ that's how we discovered great
music a a new phase happened when social
entered the scene and so people were
either sharing mixtapes or you were
creating a playlist and sharing that on
MySpace where you would discover you
know an ever increasing pool of music
via your friends as a as a filter for
for finding you know better options and
today with Pandora there's an a a a a
product where a lot of us use where you
actually are receiving personalized
music and I think what they do very
effectively is they don't get too caught
up in like going too deep in the science
because you can very much go too deep to
the point that you're not finding a
practical application of things but what
they done with the music genome product
project is that they use humans to
actually categorize the content and then
they understand based on your behavior
what your listening to what you're
liking and disliking they're able to
take you down a recommendation path and
that is a very very effective
personalization experience um another
one which being which is being used on
Yahoo today is their front page they
have a today unit where they run you
know millions of different permutations
and call it what you will there may not
be the most advanced science behind what
they're showing you even if it's just
based basic demographic data targeted
data or location targeted data but they
see you know 200 to a th% uplift on
Improvement for personally targeted
versus non-targeted uh targeted content
in that space so what we're doing is
similarly we're trying to apply that
technology where you know I imagine this
future which is not too far off where
you go to the New York Times or you go
to ESPN or you go to yahoo.com and every
single one of us has a slightly
different experience that's catered to
US based on the likelihood that you I
live in LA I like the Lakers I like Golf
and I like tennis those should be you
know if there are good stories those
should be the ones that are surfaced at
the top on ESPN for me instead of the
one siiz fits all just like you're
picking up a newspaper experience that
we get today uh so I think that that's
something that's not very far off um way
in the future and not even that far off
too is I think where uh you know things
get very very heavily dynamically
personalized because we start to get
smarter and smarter as we take these
incremental steps and uh and in some way
every story every link that you she see
could be somehow weighted to you with an
understanding of you know you're sort of
yield optimizing to the person is there
a likelihood that they're going to want
to see this or click on this and then it
gets smarter and adapts based on your
reaction to that so we should not be
saying the seeing the same Groupon deals
every day we should not be seeing the
seeing the same websites as we visit
them um the applications that we open up
should be uh somehow different
differently personalized to each of us
even if it's as basic as the location
that we're in with stuff that that Bob's
doing so uh I think that you know
thinking about things at that practical
level really gives you a sense for the
power of personalization in even the
near term um so uh something that meibo
is working on right now is this notion
of web check-ins just because we're
distributed through so many sites so we
want to start letting users check into
those sites and checking into the sites
is completely like irrelevant who cares
that it's called the check-in right we
called I'm here the kind of question is
what can you do with that data like what
interesting experience can you deliver
the user
and one of the interesting experiences
that we want to deliver that user is
let's say that you go to like this is
actually me six months ago when I knew
exactly nothing about bicycling except
that I kind of liked this notion of
bicycling um I went to bicycling.com
which is the only site that I knew about
bicycling um and I went and I checked in
because you know we have this little
Alpha product that I'm like messing
around with that's not released yet um
and when I checked in it showed me other
people who've checked in on
bicycling.com too I'm like oh okay well
maybe those people who've also Che in on
bicycling.com uh know about other cool
bicycling sites so I click someone's
picture I land on their profile page oh
they found this other bicycling site
called competitivecyclist.com so then I
go there ah now that's an interesting
site because now I can start buying cool
bicycling gear right from Competitive
Cyclist and oh by the way now
Competitive Cyclist just picked up a new
customer right and so it's literally
users discovering other people with
their same interests right back to the
interest graph um and being basically
suggested content or other websites that
would be interested to them and so the
way I think about just kind of the
interest graph or personalization of the
web like uh what Amit talked about is a
lot of how can you make the site
experience better like the New York
Times better how can you make you know
Yahoo's front page better another thing
that uh we're thinking about is look
like most people are just really
freaking bored like you know I mean how
often do you guys sit in front of your
computer you're like you have 15 minutes
to kill so you go to like that good old
standby website like for me it's CNN
like when I'm bored it's like CNN.com go
okay all right I'm still a little bored
and I have another 10 minutes to kill uh
uh New York times.com go okay still a
little bit bored I'm running out of
sites though okay maybe I'll try Google
Reader quickly you know and but you want
to find other cool stuff and so I think
if you could Leverage What are people
interested in and then hooking them up
with other people of similar interests
you could start suggesting really good
content to people that starts to solve
the boredom problem and at the end of
the day a lot of what the internet does
is just try to self board him so a quick
comment on that so it suggests that
there's a really tight uh relationship
between personalization and
social so a few weeks ago I I walked
into my 12-year-old's room and I said
what do you want for breakfast and she
said I want pancakes and I sat there
chatting with her for a few minutes and
then my wife yelled pancakes are ready
and my my younger daughter was like Dad
that was really weird and so I wonder
where is there a point on the web is it
if you add location into it if you add
all the other data you're putting in
like what you're watching on Netflix or
what you're buying at Walmart or
whatever it may be where personalization
has gotten to the point where you're
just like that's weird like they know
too much about me and I'm curious how
you guys feel about that is that coming
or are we there or what does that look
like well let me let me start by saying
that there's an interesting product
there which is is to uh on your mobile
phone to implicitly infer your interest
at the moment and then broadcast it to
your friends and so that if they think
if your app thinks that you're going to
like pancakes it'll tell your parents um
in terms of weird I think uh I think
we'll progressively get more weird I
think that what we think is uh weird now
will become normal I mean weird like
some people might consider that privacy
was invaded or what is privacy
privacy are definitely have definitely
changed dramatically over the last 10
years and will continue to change in
ways that will surprise us when we have
kids and so on I think that there's a
real uh I I mean there's a real change
and there's a real intergenerational
change in in terms of perception of
privacy and I I think let to add to that
um you know you you mentioned when
people were scared of putting their
credit card numbers online and I
remember when I started in Myspace
people were scared of putting a photo
online or putting their real name online
and I was scared I was like I'm not I
don't know if I'm going to do this but
it's you know once I did it uh I started
to see value in it and uh and so I think
you know the the sort of stage that
we're at with personalization is
somewhat similar where what is happening
right now is there there's a there's a
fear in the unknown like right now you
know we we project these these potential
disaster scenarios because we don't know
what's going to happen and so I think
what will more logically end up
happening is what you have to do is
first educate the user as to what's
happening you show them value for what's
happening and as a result of that you
build trust in your relationship with
them um and then they're going to be a
little bit more forthcoming with their
data um I don't know you know if or when
we'll get to a place where everything's
completely transparent I can't imagine
that being the case so I think that we
will have certain things about us if
it's health related maybe financially
related maybe not um that uh are kept a
little bit more secure a little bit more
private uh but you know I think that
like every sort of disruptive technology
we deal with those hurdles as they come
and we'll figure out the right way to
react with them to react to them but I
think that by far the value that we'll
get out of it very much outweighs the
risk that we're taking um so it's very
much in our interest to push those
boundaries and try to figure out where
that equilibrium
is so I do have a a weird experience
that I can share actually uh it it
actually relates to your old company
mypace um there is
no it's it's
all was still there no no he left no no
but in general it's it's actually I want
to talk about um this notion that I mean
um it really communication of that and
you know people knowing what it's been
done to them I mean that would define uh
how weird it is or how you know
beautiful or how you know serendipitous
it is um if you search from from my name
on on online I mean there is there so
you you know you find a Facebook page
which is no problem I I authoriz them to
to share my name um to to the world and
there's LinkedIn right and then there is
this other site who apparently got my
data my age where I've been blah blah
blah from my old account at Myspace and
I had no clue that Myspace was doing
this I mean that level of data sharing
probably weren't it was actually they
were probably crawling it yeah craw but
that's the thing it's it's most likely
was craw actually but this notion that
the compan is taking responsibility and
actually taking steps to not letting
these things happen right I mean like it
or not one of the interesting things is
that
defend because because no and I think it
interesting because it was in this time
of change where you weren't necessarily
aware that was happening but it was
because the the information was public
the same way that Twitter is now very
obviously public information at the time
that wasn't necessarily perceived as
obviously public so there was this weird
that is my point still I mean that that
level of um you know unwanted sharing of
information could have been communicated
with me as a user someone could have
sent an email to I mean these These are
techniques that I think if people take
actions to them it would actually take
out the weirdness part I mean I I would
have been totally cool with it if I got
an email from my hey look there's a
chance that our website is getting
scraped your information might be out
there come back and actually check off
these privacy things on MySpace to be
lock it down boom I mean one simple
email would have solved the whole thing
now I'm on to I'm on this haunting I
mean I'm this quest to somehow tell this
website to remove my information which
you already scraped and it's already in
their hands and I don't know what to do
with it although I think that's
unrealistic to expect mypace to do that
I mean for one crawling technology
becoming that's one technique of
handling the situation but I think I
think what this conversation does
highlight is like the culture is moving
to where people just expect like hey if
it's public it's public if it's private
it's private and they have an
expectation that they get served that
way the thing that we all have to deal
with as an industry is there are going
to be one to two% of users who become
very very offended by what has happened
even if we set it up the right way right
and so we need to be able to serve those
people who become very very offended and
kind of make it right with them and so
every company's got to figure that out
yeah so we talked a little bit briefly
about personalization based on social
graph and we talked about
personalization based on interest graph
and maybe the next one to talk about is
based on
location um you know there are all these
physical check-in services like for
square and guala and Facebook has places
and different ones like that so I'm
curious what you guys think uh we'll
start with Bak this time you know what
what is kind of the location based
personalization and maybe compare that
to how people consider personalization
on the web and what will be the main
challenges for location based
personalization so um so there is there
is this um so there is there is this
notion that I
mean we we we seeing this um right now I
mean you you you normally know your the
places that you that around the place
you live the place you go to school and
probably on your way I mean to me cities
I mean you're living in a city that just
the lights are all off you don't know
where to find things that would be
really cool to you I mean find the next
Burger Joint the next B that's really
would match your interest all the all
these other things I me how do you
currently what's the service that would
actually allow you to to find them for
you and let you know um aside from the
fact if you're living in Hollywood and
you have you know personal assistant
who's just walking around actually finds
stuff for you to do um so I think we
living in an age I think a next
generation of Technologies are needed to
basically um to help you find um much
like how you know companies like such as
gravity or others are doing it to find
you know other contents that that would
match your interest that are on the web
um we can actually find them on on in in
actual physical places um the problem
with the old school way of doing things
um CF based like how Amazon and Netflix
were doing it was that I mean the
collaborative filing way of doing things
you you would have to have had a lot of
signals established between how people
relate to places so all these check-ins
are wonderful but it's just there's not
enough data being captured right now to
actually use the old school way of doing
things um actually I do have something
we can actually put on the screen I mean
I don't know if you there's there's any
there's there's a graph that actually
talks about this this point uh so
talking about challenges so I so from
the perspective of is it interesting is
it useful absolutely I think it will
move um offline Commerce it will move a
lot of things that would be um um that
would you it help it will help you to
find um places or deals or whatever that
would match truly your interest as
you're on the go but then the the
challenges are there's you don't have
enough signals that are established to
be able to use um normal way of doing
recommendations to find them um actually
if you have the previous slide before
this I'm going to show you just they're
doing two slides yeah so this is how
this is a heat map of um us basically
analyzing um roughly about 500,000 um
users as they've interacted with places
by rating them this is the map of Bay
Area so if you're living in Bay Area um
in local places we can do a pretty I
mean people can do a pretty good job of
doing potentially recommendations um
because there's enough people who've
interacted with places that you can find
if you like so and so you want and the
other person likes one so and this other
extra thing you can also um we can also
recommend it to you but then if you go
to the next slide but so the challenges
if but doing that on a large scale um
there's an inherent problem um that is
people are not moving people are not
people that are in pal Alto are not
checking in in New York as as often as
you want as often as you want to so your
the the information is not traveling so
it's it's only 15 person 15% of people
um are basically rating or checking into
places that are not local to them so if
you know a lot of good things about you
when you're in palal now you get up and
go to London let's say or even New York
so what you're saying is you need the
interest graph overlay on this and then
everything will work great yeah because
exactly if you know if you have the DNA
of places I mean much like how Pandora
does it for music if you know how to
describe um places then that would
change everything because then it
doesn't matter how many people are
establishing signals between places it's
matter of if you know how to describe a
place and if you have an interest graph
that evolves for the user then you're
just you're you're you're free to roam
around you can just move around
everywhere and um right now we've proven
almost 90% level accuracy if you can
find places that would actually match
your actual interest anywhere you go I
think what U with Bach and clever
sensoring is really cool and uh a very
very like you know it's going to be an
awesome value proposition when you can
actually sort of be be guided around
within locations um the way that that I
like to look at and I think is similar
to what sep was saying earlier is that
it's kind of it's the location is
somewhat of it's another data point
within your graph where uh in a in a
strange way like location conceptually
be it physical or digital is somewhat
the same right like we when we go to a
town and we have a bunch of options for
restaurants or bars to go to it's almost
similar to going online and we have a
bunch of options for websites to visit
or even being at an individual website
um if it's a new site or whatever it
might be and having a bunch of options
for what might be a cool story for me um
and so what what we're all trying to do
is figure out how do we help you
navigate through be it a physical or a
digital location based on what's going
to be personally relevant to you and
that may be you know what's what's
what's the right way of determining the
shortest path from you to the thing that
you're probably going to like the most
and there are a lot of different
algorithms there's a lot of different
methods for helping you find that
sometimes it's the simplest ones that
are the most effective but the way that
that we tend to see it is is uh you know
if it's if it's a physical location or
even a a link or a website itself that's
something that you know what we're
trying to do is help you navigate that
sort of be your guide to help you
discover really cool things on it that
are going to be catered to your
interests um so with look uh with the
internet and kind of interfacing with
the real world there's this category of
company that's begun to spring up a
little bit which makes physical Goods uh
so like Webkins is the best first
example they make a toy and usually the
margins on that kind of physical good
product is driven down to zero really
fast as competitors copy them um but
then what they do is they interface the
toy in some way with the internet and
they create network effect or some kind
of community for that physical toy and
then they keep their margins up on the
physical good side so it's an example of
the internet interfacing with the real
world and I think location is just it's
another example of the internet
interfacing with the real world but I
think you can go far beyond like I'm at
a restaurant right now right because we
all stare at like the dancing pixels of
our screens a lot of hours of the day
but there are also a lot of hours of the
day where forget about like where we are
we're just doing stuff in the real world
maybe we're in transit maybe we're
reading a magazine lo and behold uh you
know maybe we're like doing real kind of
human interaction things and so I think
the question is how can uh the internet
provide you some richer experience or
some more information or help you
discover more cool stuff or connect you
with other people based on the actions
that you're taking in the real world and
the best example of kind of how this is
beginning to work uh kind of abstracted
out a location and just like inter
interface with the real world is QR
codes in Japan like that's actually
pretty close right cuz it's not just Q
it's not just Om I'm at a restaurant
it's like oh I just saw this ad in a
magazine and I want to learn more about
it or oh I'm at this store and I want to
learn more about their product scan
Discover right so I think if you
abstract a little bit away from the goo
notion into just the interface of
Internet with real world notion I don't
know what it's going to look look like
in America maybe there'll be QR codes uh
but something's going to happen there
it's going to be very
interesting yeah I'll also use this and
since Bob economics gave a good answer
to the location question I'll do the
same as Seth and use this to segue to
another observation uh which is one of
the things that uh uh made kind of this
location uh location aware Computing
possible is the fact that we all now
have computers with sensors on them
right we have computers that know our
location um and that provides a
tremendous opportunity around location
um the more sensors we have on our
computers the more kind of opportunities
there become not only around location
but around all sorts of stuff so um you
add a temperature sensor you add an
accelerometer you um you don't even
think about your phone as a computer but
why don't uh when cars start opening up
apis then you have different typ of
location because this should be my car
ke why why do I have a car ke it's
really annoying battery dies and you
don't can start your I know about I
don't know what to do with that problem
or I mean even more specifically I mean
why isn't uh somebody building an app to
just show me the McDonald's when I'm
driving by right so um and third party
should McDonald's
app Starbucks app but not in my car it's
on my phone um and so uh so I think in
general kind of I I'll not answer the
question of where location based
personalization is but I'll I'll suggest
that there other kind of opportunities
for personalization will arise as more
sensors get added to different kinds of
computers general question here how do
you see the interest graph and
augmenting reality coming together
because I know I'm working with a
company right now we're doing a lot of
stuff with a reality and interest graphs
I just want to hear what you guys think
about that
um I mean argumented reality it's just
another way of interacting I mean the
data that you show when you look at look
through this screen can come from
anywhere I mean certainly um interest
graph all discussions around this notion
that instead of showing you when you're
looking through a lens instead of
showing you um 100 different dots
interest graphs will help you to show
that only five that would actually be
relevant to you so it makes that
experience 10 times better because the
screen is not wed by irrelevant stuff
Mak sense that's it I think this just
simp yeah like one of the things we're
working on where I would take my camera
and show it point two all a a little
bubble pops up over you and gives me
everything I need to know about you
based on what's out on the way so if you
had a conference or somewhere like that
you can actually see people you want to
meet you want to find out where you want
to meet that person not you very quickly
identify the person need de but that's
not interest graph that's that's the
notion of that's that's the notion of
search no no no the interest gra would
be is what their interests are in what
they do based on what I'm interested in
and being able to see
them common interests and use that as
like an icebreaker exactly kind of weird
I want to know more about you before I
get to you than you know that I know
about think you you just answered my
question about what would be too weird
for
me got another question
yeah yeah earlier you mentioned this
idea of the cultural norms of what kind
of information people are will to
you know is changing I'm curious your
perspective of you know we have
regulations for to
people's not I'm curious if you you guys
vision is for those of personal
information more sensitive if you see a
change a cultural change in that realm
as
well uh well I'll I'll answer that
question so I um I some students of M
uh a few years ago uh said they're
starting a company that will um it's a
toolbar that collects your entire
browsing history and then it'll use it
to personalize search results um and at
the time I kind of tried to dissuade
them from doing that because I didn't
think that people would be interested in
sharing their whole browsing history
with a startup that nobody knows about
they had enough problems with what the
kinds of things that we were doing at
Google um and so to to trust their
information to this startup so they came
back to me last week and they said um so
now we have about 8 million users and I
said how did you get 8 million users um
and they said well we launched this
feature that that people can also share
your entire browsing history with
everybody you know on Facebook and that
made it viral and so the fact that I was
pretty sure that people wouldn't do it
this far but people then the the thing
that made it work was people did it even
further than that so it's very hard to
to do legislation when there are such
shifting cultural norms um and also when
there's difference differences uh in
terms of uh gener generationally right
so a lot of the people who were doing
this was were younger now what I think
uh where I think legislation may be able
to go is to be be able to do things like
require uh control require Choice
require transparency and require data
portability um and those four things I
think
um despite like to be able to use a
service and choose to not have your
personally identifiable information
shared is something that's nice or to be
able to choose to uh to say I don't want
to use the service anymore I want to
move to another service and I want to
move my data with me I think those four
things are really uh where legislation
can happen um great discussion really
enjoy it thank you so much my question
is on the monetization of this
personalization services so what do you
guys see as the the way that people can
companies can actually like make profit
from that would it be a freemale model
where you know over time users are will
to pay for the services or should it be
like more Enterprise like only big
companies for advertisment base uh I
guess like personalization will work
like how do you see like like companies
actually being able to make profit in
the future not in like the next two or 3
years but in 10 years time would users
be will to like pay for this and be part
of their lives yeah at at at the broad
level that we've been talking about
around like there's this generalized
notion of an interest graph and you can
do lots of different stuff with it I
think it's very hard to pin oh and
therefore this is how you'll make money
because the best way to make money on uh
products in the internet is usually
figure out the very specific way users
use your product and and then make money
off of that so like in the example I
gave of the way we're thinking about
interest graph like let's say that you
did have me and I was at
bing.com and I clicked on someone's
picture probably because I want to find
other cool bicycling stuff well that
sounds like search right I mean and I'm
going to that person's profile because I
want to find other bicycling stuff so
there's probably room to do a keyword
bid between specialized track and
surveillance
and say hey who's willing to pay the
most to get me to go to their site right
um so that probably looks like a search
monetization play um but you know Amit
probably has ideas on how to monetize
you know making the New York Times a
more relevant experience um based on the
interest graph so I think it just
depends on how on the actual expression
of the data to the user I
agree there was two questions last time
now a quick one um and pardon my
ignorance it's scaring me a little bit
but I'm thinking of uh emerging markets
and uh I've got Iran and China on my
mind
so when you have uh I mean you can't
even speak politics with a
CCP liaison in the room when you're
dealing with Executives at a Chinese
company and when I hear you talk about
almost an AI type of we'll find what you
want and send it to your friends um and
they'll see what you're thinking about
uh like kind of a bolt of fear goes
through me a little bit because I have
sisters in Iran that sometimes uh
they'll post things on Facebook you know
without their montro or without without
proper Head Start but just uh how does
this this
information is going to be uh Gathering
itself and possibly you know I don't
want it's not the end of the world here
but you're going to have two types of
users in my opinion in an Emerging
Market one is going to be someone who
doesn't understand what they're putting
in uh which is scary and second is going
to be uh someone who is now knows what
you do and is afraid which will shoe off
potential
consumers big question question I'm
sorry how do you it sounds like we're
talking about the developed World in
this conversation and I'm thinking of
you know potential 400 million users um
um I mean in China what i' say what I
say to that is I think um the potential
for all so social Technologies not just
personalization but this I mean with
Twitter and Facebook and everything I
mean the potential for surveillance is a
real u a real Danger uh to Consumers not
just in the developing world but
everywhere um and I don't really have a
good answer for that um I mean I I think
that people will continue to build tools
that allow people to express themselves
um and people will continue to use those
tools uh and uh there's a use those
tools very publicly um and they have
wondrous potentials like uh they can you
can build your own person personal brand
through these or you can learn a lot
through lots of people communicating uh
but they also have uh downsides which
are which are things like uh
surveillance um and it reminds me so
Richard fan said this thing where he
went to Thailand and a Buddhist monk
told him to every person is given a key
to heaven and that same key opens the
doors to hell and he said that
technology is the same way is that a lot
of the same technology that
enables wondrous opportunities also
enables nefarious
opportunities
without this is just gonna happen I mean
like look my my mother it God bless her
she just went on Facebook like and
someone commented on some picture she
put up there and she responds to the
comment was something she should not
have said in public the the good because
she had no clue she thought she was you
know privately answering that person
fortunately my sister saw it calls my
mother and it's like Mom it's
Facebook delete that you know and then
my sister of course IMS me immediately
it's like can you believe what Mom just
did um so you know it Toby World your
mother people are going to screw this
stuff up a lot on any new technology and
again it kind of goes back to the tools
to try to help people remove this kind
of stuff but it's just risk yeah it's
exciting get through this disruptive
part of technology so but those are I
those are
fears we'll get through but we're early
stage no but but I think one last
comment on that is just I think as long
as there are tools there to correct the
mistakes right it's not like it's you
you've said it and it's you can't delete
it anymore it's just I mean you as long
as the as long as there there things or
you can furthermore you can say from now
on I don't want to share so on so as
long as these tools are there I think we
would give um a lot of uh I mean you
should give a lot of credit to to to
people they can learn and they can pick
up these things very very quickly much
like you know your mom probably wouldn't
do this anymore because she knows now
you never know you never know you know
but but people also will evolve I mean
we should give credit to people's
intelligence I mean they will get things
one or two mistakes are made and after
next the third one hopefully it's going
to be avoided as long as the the tools
are
[Music]
there